fighting in the main event co-main event
i would just make a poster with homs on
it it would just say hamzat usd 273
the hype is real as real as it gets
hamza
shamayev is an absolute [ __ ] monster
he's ranked number 11. he's fighting the
number two guy in the world for a reason
he's jumping the q because he's that
goddamn good
and uh again this is no shade on gilbert
burns he's an amazing fighter he's
number two at welterweight for a reason
he had the the world champion the
pound-for-pound goat
kamara who's been rocked and a bit of
trouble and obviously he gives them all
he can handle and practice that's what
everyone kept telling me practice
practice practice i told you practice
doesn't mean [ __ ] and we learned that in
that fight
so gilbert burns is one of the best
welterweights we have to offer
phenomenal jiu jitsu
world champion the gui multiple times
and you know he's beat some guys and
i think if you're a hamza hater again i
don't know if hamzad has haters i i i
don't know what you'd hate on
but if you look at
uh
if you are a gilbert guy and you're like
man gilbert can give this get this done
look what he did against one boy
thompson right he he took him down and
held him and you know did his thing
controlled the fight and was never
really in trouble with wonder boy and he
took him down he only has four losses
sure sure i get all that
but then i i want you to step back and
think about this he had wonder boy
for 15 minutes completely controlled him
on the ground couldn't submit wonder boy
who's maybe a purple belt
you think he's gonna take
down and control him and submit hamzad
a bigger better grappler not a chance
not a chance i ju and this is no shade
on gilroy i know it sounds like i'm
throwing shayla and giver i'm not
homesick i'm telling you man i'm so high
on homs at i'm not nothing is better to
me in this [ __ ] world in any sport
than when a prospect is coming up
through the ranks
and there's these urban legends about
his training camp and what he does to
gus finn and latifi and his coaches tell
me you haven't seen [ __ ] and then you
know he beats the brakes off your boy
jinglang beats the [ __ ] out of him
and goes from there and goes to a
grappling match against a middleweight
and molly wops him
the the amount of hype and mythical
stories that we've heard about hamzat
and just the come up and there's no
reason we shouldn't believe it because
every time he's performed he's validated
this insane hype train and i am all for
it i am hanging off his dagger standing
nuts harder than anybody you're gonna
listen to i think he's the most talented
fighter we've seen in [ __ ] years
he is a conor mcgregor
dagestanian but bigger
more skilled overall
and more tenaci he's a mean [ __ ]
dude he's just this badass he's this
mythical
logical creature he's the [ __ ] he
he's that bigfoot in dak standing he's
the bigfoot in sweden that we never get
to see finally we get to see him we get
to see him against the number two
[ __ ] welterweight in the world and
what's insane to me is saying this i
think he mops the floor with gilbert
burns i think he absolutely annihilates
him and what's even crazier is
i don't see anybody on the ufc roster
giving him any sorts of [ __ ] issues
that's what's crazy to me and that's
what i love i know it's romantic i'm a
romantic i love the story i love the
narrative of this dagger standing
[ __ ] monster doing this thing
i love all of it and i'm all here for it
take my [ __ ] money if the ufc said
hey it's a hundred dollars and you can
only watch hamzat fight i would [ __ ]
pay it in a heartbeat anytime he fights
i'm on the goddamn hamza trade i don't
know if he has merch let me know chen
i'm [ __ ] buying it hopefully he has
his own merch and i know him and darren
till are [ __ ] besties now and
hopefully darren till's taking a thing
or two from him and he's gonna parlay it
in something else i know how's that
launch his own youtube channel which is
[ __ ] blowing up as well the guy's
just crushing it dude he's crushing it
this is the ufc store merch hopefully he
has his own merch
i wonder if he has his own what i mean
i'll buy the ufc much i have an issue
with that
have you ever seen anybody rocking the
[ __ ] uh
well i guess reeboks out they don't even
they still do fight kick
kids though don't they what
venom they venom does the fight kits now
is it
also he has a website but it's not it
says coming soon so he'll probably have
merch after oh my god that guy would
make a fortune off merch yeah
the cool merch you could do with that
dude let's look at the fight kits here
mike's just hoping he wins because mike
has a hamsa rookie card worth how much
mike
three or four grand right now becomes
champ that goes up to what
you're gonna sell it
if he gets attending us yeah i mean it's
fight game how long can you know i don't
know
so you got the authentic one ah
it has the big crypto thing so but this
is homs i care this is just
there you go shirt
hoodie shirt
that looks pretty cool
you're not digging it
i mean it does look cool it looks very
it's very under armour-ish right like
you're gonna
i will use this first thing something a
little more hanzo looks so much cooler i
think than shimada
i mean there's nothing that just blows
me on there it's just so basic how do
they not focus on
hamza what's the back say
i am your king
i mean the cool merc the boogeyman mercy
i am your king
not matt that shirt
i don't wear a ton of blue but
it looks like a cool baseball type shirt
uh this product ships from a third party
product could take initial seven ten
business days of ship from the vendor
product time will be seven ten business
days regardless of shipping option
chooses oh well that's not ideal
i'm i'm all here for it though and also
at you know he
when he fought jingling he uh
his camp was worried about him getting
to welterweight right and because he's
such a big welterweight and it's his
advantage in in so many aspects from the
grappling to the power everything he's a
bigger welterweight he's going to be
massive massive
as far as physically over gilbert burns
gilbert burns is a smaller welterweight
so he's a big favorite for a reason the
first three five i'm sorry the last
three fights on the main card are all
complete mismatches as far as vegas odds
go now does that mean they're going to
be landslides nope oh check me out does
that mean this can be landslide
you know minute finishes no i don't
think that um oh that's your card mike's
card
sealed sealed
mike's stoked mike collects cards he
does
nothing wrong with that man no man i'm
all about it
um
so you know hamza i i will say this for
a hamzat fan
i think he has
i'll be kind of
conservative on this i think he's gonna
he has two more fights at welterweight
before he's sick of
being on a diet all the goddamn time
i know he was in shape for a fight two
months ago he was walking around at the
the weight to make welterweight at 170.
so he's a bigger guy so what i think
happens is uh hamza beats gilbert burns
if he goes in there and absolutely
starches him like i'm talking a minute
two minutes just molly wops gilbert
burns
he puts the ufc in quite the predicament
because
the ufc has promised leon edwards the
title shot
god has he earned it right we all want
leon edwards to get what he deserves
he's earned it but the ufc is gonna be
in such a tough spot because
the demand for hamza to get a title shot
if he completely beats the [ __ ] out of
gilbert burns
is going to be so insane and the ufc is
about money they're about money they're
not about
doing the right thing all the time but
you know kamar usman is coming off
surgery there has been no official
announcement of him versus on edwards in
july or uh june or or august
so
with that not being confirmed unless
they confirm it this week the ufc is
going to be in quite the predicament
they really are man
because if hamzap mops the floor with
gilbert burns number two guy in the
world
what do you do
we know what's going to get numbered
we know what's going to get numbers and
it's kamara versus hamza yeah and
hamzat's not going to be around what to
wait too long
um and also hamza again one of the
reasons i love him reminds me such of
connor when he's coming up he doesn't
want to sit on the shelf he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about your title he's already
said if they give connor to the title
shot it makes sense yeah dude he's a
huge star he's trying to make money
whatever they want to do
he doesn't care about that stuff he just
wants to compete at all costs
so if the ufc does go all right honda we
hear the demand from the fans you beat
the gilbert burns you deserve a title
shot we're going to give it to you but
it's probably not going to be till
december maybe early 2023 depending how
leona where leon edwards and newsman
does
which is another fight we can get into i
do think that's a tougher fight for
kamar usman um but lin you tell me leon
edwards beat hamzat
tough fight
tough fight so i i i do think uh the ufc
is going to do the right thing i'm just
saying they're going to be a bit of a
predict predicament i do think they're
in do leonardo where it's uspin sometime
mid late summer
but hamzat if he gets past the way i
think he's going to get past gilbert
burns
he's not going to wait he wants to
compete and then you got a guy
who has a ton of press a ton of eyeballs
on him right now for i would say the
wrong reasons in colby covington against
you know his issues with mozville at the
steakhouse in miami where he's
sucker-punched
but you do hamzad vs kobe covington
that's what you do
you gilbert he gilbert burns you pass
that test you give him the next guy in
line because he'll be ranked number two
so you give him kobe covington and then
he'll just wait for kumar usman and then
it's on to the middleweights
because he's naturally a middleweight
and you know they're they're they have
our guy [ __ ] uh he's even ranked yeah
they have sean strickland number four so
then you have sean strickland
uh is facing the guy
who beat
um izzy in kickboxing knocked him out
you have him climbing through the
rankings and i do think uh strickland
said underdog in that fight which is
surprising to me i
you know from what i've seen you know
the guy's a stud the guy is an absolute
stud
but um i i do think it's a big jump to
go to sean strickland from what he's
been competing at but if he were to beat
uh sean strickling
you know then then you have that fun
story of which i'm sorry of izzy
first what's his name chin alex bahia
bahia
that makes sense but outside that the
middle weight division has nothing to
offer so hamza comes right in there
yet izzy hamzat dude so many awesome
messages he hums off
and then we're going scizzler because
also hamza with the strength and what he
does in training camp
you got light heavyweight too
who wants it daddy who wants it hamzat
has the potent this is what i absolutely
[ __ ] adore about the ufc and there's
nothing like it there's absolutely
nothing like it a little bit of a
patrick mahomes vibe i guess
you know he was picked late and then
comes in and
you know they they have uh
chiefs had their starting quarterback
and alex smith and they take a chance
and this young rookie from texas tech
who
got to be honest
turned the ball over in college and
didn't blow your hair back but he's a
gunslinger comes in the nfl and he's the
best quarterback in the nfl now not
named aaron rodgers shout out to rogers
but he's up there man he's [ __ ]
dangerous
his come up was cool
very cool took the nfl by storm
similar to that man where he has the
potential to just take over the ufc for
the first time he's a smaller guy not
[ __ ] around 145 like connor did and
55 then can you know really shouldn't be
fine at 70 but he can if it's the right
match up hamzot's a guy at 170
is the best in the world at 185 we will
see against izzy i'm still obviously
super high and izzy and that light
heavyweight he can [ __ ] around and play
the game in all three of those divisions
it is fantastic
the world is your oyster my man the
world is your oyster
and it is so goddamn exciting now what's
going to be hilarious
is if he gets absolutely starch on
saturday by gilbert burns and you guys
watch this and then i get all the smoke
from gilbert burn fans
which i encourage that it would be
hilarious and all this hype stops which
is also
awesome to see too it's hilarious
that's how hard that's the fight game
man mike's just worried about his card
and making money but the fight game will
humble anybody but
i ju with homs i just don't see a hole
in his game yet i just don't
i just don't not yet
i you know the the only guy to give him
issues that middleweight would be izzy
with his the matchups but
if he goes in there and does what we
think he's capable of doing against
gilbert burns it's gonna get so scary in
a great way and it's so romantic and
it's so hollywood it's a marvel movie
he's a [ __ ] he's the boogie man it's
so [ __ ] dope
and it's also terrifying too because as
much
i haven't been talking [ __ ] but as much
gas that i've given hamzat
the fight game is such a s
[ __ ] it's such a cold-hearted
[ __ ] all this could stop if he loses
the gilbert burns on saturday that's why
this is fun the stakes are so high
and my god if there's a stock i'm
investing in homsat dude you guys
[ __ ] know this
he's a [ __ ] problem at welterweight
at middleweight at light heavyweight i
would i would back him against anybody
in the world the only fight i'm not
crazy for him about is is he because
izzy's a bad [ __ ] i still
believe this if aliens came down we're
like
all right man we're going to blow up
this earth but we're going to keep the
ufc but we're only going to keep a few
fighters who should we watch i'd say
watch izzy right now say watch izzy now
come saturday
come saturday
if hamza beats the [ __ ] out of gilbert
burns i'd say watch hamzat
he's a [ __ ] savage and that'd whisper
in the alien's air what he did what he
planned to do to conor mcgregor talk
[ __ ] about a guy he doesn't even know
because they're both dagestanian and
he's gonna fly to [ __ ] dublin beat
the [ __ ] out of him
i'd whisper that in the aliens and say
for reals i'll say yeah dog that's what
you're dealing with
and nobody's been able to figure him out
take him
take him but also take me because i'm
the hype drink
i'm his hype man i'm his flavor flav
that's what i am
the and if i'm the ufc dude the poster
is just this is no shade on any of the
champions
the poster is just hamzot
and then everybody else small at the
bottom
that's what i do
that's what i'd be very black and white
with everybody i'd be very honest
we're all in on him man we're trying to
make him the biggest star in the world
you see his youtube numbers you see his
social media following this guy has
shown no
chinks in the armor
zero
giant hanzo everybody else small ufc 273
hamzat buy it
very black buy it or else
be sick be amazing